a couple months until the wedding
literally it's so crazy because it is
June first so that means that we're like
two ones away yeah which is insane
everything planned is everything good no
not of these plan invitation everything
is already out baby
they just went out yeah they went out on
Wednesday I think your guys's wedding is
similar to timing with Rachel so is that
hard for bachelor nation to like have to
choose actually rachel is so nice
no they don't have to choose of course
not but rachel is so nice because we did
set our date about a year in advance and
she just said it I feel like February
ish and she came to me and she said do
you guys know your what's your date cuz
I don't want to we want to make sure
that's not on the same weekend this
season are we gonna have the Kenan that
get married are we gonna get married and
then have the kid and I gonna have a
party at my wedding dress but I never
want to be pregnant in a wedding dress
to see the wedding I know it's not
televised but on the new the new YouTube
show well who knows what will happen we
don't know how to say right now we have
the digital series called what now which
is documenting our lives Tanner and
Jade's Nick and that kind of shows the
wedding planning process right now and
everything that went into it and like
having to deal with the Tanner situation
and the guest list and everything with
that and so we honestly don't know
what's gonna happen past that but but of
course if we were to be able to do
another season of what now we would
definitely have the wedding included in
it somehow you know the Tanner situation
who is gonna officiate the wedding now
that he is expecting his baby that week
which is very exciting very happy for
both them but we I mean I wasn't right
now still him with with somebody that
we've asked to be prepared in case you
can't make but we also we love our
backup officiant so much I don't even
want to consider him a backup they're
both first place in my heart
I just Tanner has a plan if the baby is
born a week early then he's gonna make
it
if it's within the week
it'll be a little bit more challenging
but it's gonna be all play by ear but
our backup officiant will have
definitely a role in the wedding either
way is it Nick vile no it's not Nick but
Nick will Nick's a part of the charisma
party he has a job at the wedding as
well no it's not great we really hope
Chris comes though we give them a
wedding off
just enjoy sit down eat the food dance
enjoy yourself no work for Chris yeah
you're gonna feel we are gonna be really
sad if Chris doesn't go so yeah I know
that you had like a bachelorette party
and it was very boyband theme are we
gonna get a boyband to perform at the
wedding oh you know what some boy
banders will be invited to the wedding
we think we're gonna die let's throw out
some last-minute invite Wow
Lance AJ ah those here good you're warm
you're hot so we'll see we'll see will
they perform will you ask them to do
that they're not our we do have a
special performer we're very excited
about but they're actually not a boy
bander house it was another musical
passion I've had in my life yes is it
something @dt come on may have even told
Tuesday's sure it's David Cook from
American Idol yeah he is on my favorite
artist ever and I mean my favorite
American Idol ever so it's really cool
that he is gonna perform on our wedding
we think you guys like the warmest voice
ever he just could like warm up an
entire room so we love that that
romanticism yeah we we kind of joking
one day about like about who you know oh
you know what if David Cook sang in our
wedding and then we were like man that's
such a now we have to like we have to do
it so we were able to talk to the right
people and and he was he wanted to do it
so it all worked out yeah have you
talked about if you're gonna take his
last name I feel like we all know you is
like Ashlee I know it's so crazy I'm
definitely gonna take his name legally
and when we're married I definitely want
to go by haben I think like
professionally like on camera well I
refer to myself as Ashlee I totally but
in paper I think it'll be Haven
soon a people yeah Ashley H doesn't have
the same race have you been watching
this season of a Bachelorette what do
you think what do we think of Luke P
Luke P is a little bit mean to say the
least
he's definitely full of yet well yeah I
mean the whole I loved like I'm falling
in love with you after literally maybe
seeing her for a total of an hour and a
half yeah and like 48 hours into the
process I did start developing feelings
for you like before I have ever met and
the connection seriously I've had with
you I'm not joking
being 100 series I've been I've never
thought like connection like this in my
whole life my feelings for you you've
been growing like it's so fast I am
starting to fall in love with you I am
this Monday we got to see the episode
early right now but you guys should
definitely good drama and like I'm not
even joking they were saying like the
most dramatic there's a moment in this
episode we're both Ashley and I looked
each other like there is no way he just
said that and so it's we get as much
Lukey this week as we have every other
week so far it's a good character we
really like Hanna we know you know Tyler
G was removed by production do you guys
know anything about what happened with
that we don't nothing no I mean honest
let me know as much as everybody else
does because we just googled it and
that's like you know speculation my last
questions I'm getting wrapped up but I
feel like Hanna has been very open about
her religious beliefs and her sexuality
and that's something that you were also
very open about so what do you think
about what she's saying and now she's
handling everything I think there's some
good teasers in there I don't we don't
really know the context of it so I don't
even want to jump and like give an
opinion right now I know that definitely
he's raised an eyebrow with Jared and
teasers but oh yeah I mean who how is it
not raised an eyebrow
with things that were said was like is
she are people's butts shaming her and
then obviously there were things that
Hanna said that you're asking or is that
taken out of context it's just like this
kind of like weird situation that they
keep teasing to that obviously all of us
want to see in its entirety to really
know okay what is the context of this
what is being said what's going on in
what guy with nobody I really don't know
but according to you know what we've
seen so far he seems to be the most
guilty of them so you know frontrunner
for you guys
Jed is your favorite yeah we we're down
with the Jed movement is just so laid
back and relaxed and he's just not
trying too hard and that's very nice
it's relaxing to watch him yeah Connor I
like hotter to cars nice I like a little
post-it notes that he did I think it's
nice underdog right now yeah stand out
thank you guys so much
[Music]